et avec nous pour ce match des idées en
direct sur public sénat ce soir jean
sébastien ferjou bienvenue fondateur et
directeur d'atlantico yves derai est
également avec nous bien venu rédacteur
en chef de forbes france merci à tous
les deux tout la droite crie haro sur le
pnf et considère que la prison ferme
pour nicolas sarkozy c'est absolument
inacceptable on a même entendu à nadine
morano qui parle d'acharnement
judiciaire de méthodes douteuses du pmf
que pensez vous de cet axe de défense
jean sébastien ferjou parce que je
trouve étonnant ce n'est pas que la
droite s'en émeuvent c'est plutôt que la
gauche ne s'en émeuvent pas parce que
derrière le cas de nicolas sarkozy il ya
un problème qui devrait inquiéter tous
les français normalement les
conversations entre un client et son
avocat n'ont pas à être écouté alors je
veux bien qu'on fait des entourloupes
juridique pour dire qu'il s'agit de
grands mafieux et que donc comme il
s'agit de grands mafieux qui préparent
des crimes entre eux
ça méritait le fait qu'on les écoute
s'il faut rappeler quand même là j'ai
même conclue par un non-lieu info il
faut s'en souvenir que les juges emploie
la technique du filet dérivant et vous
écoute enfin et se met à écouter nicolas
sarkozy mais rebecca je suis certain que
si je vous écoute ou si j'écoute pendant
trois mois à la totalité des membres du
gouvernement à l'heure actuelle mais ou
de ceux des gouvernements précédents peu
importe du trafic d'influencé en
entendrez parce que c'est quasiment
consubstantiel à la nature même du
pouvoir n'ont qu'un on avait un
président qui essayait de se renseigner
sur une procédure qui le visait dont on
voit bien qu'il ya souvent eu un
calendrier judiciaire qui
correspondaient à des échéances
politiques importants dans le pays
donc oui moi je trouve que ça pose une
véritable question démocratique est ce
que ce à quoi sur l'indépendance de la
justice donc c'est ya un problème dans
le clan je sais pas si c'est
l'indépendance dé la justice parce que
je pense que les magistrats ou juste ton
idéologie
oui la passe de la justice de manière
générale d'ailleurs deux certains
magistrats et en particulier des
magistrats du parquet national
financiers oui je pense que ça trouble
et que alors qu'on est déjà dans une
époque de crise de défiance oui parce
que qui une peine on verra bien quelle
sera la condamnation à l'arrivée enfin
deux ans de prison ferme souvenons quand
même des réquisitions qui ont été faites
à l'encontre d'alain juppé ou de jacques
chirac dans des affaires qui étaient
quand même largement aussi grave en
matière d'emplois fictifs à la mairie de
paris ou de détournement de fonds il ya
un moment le deux poids deux mesures
auxquelles se livrent la justice encore
une fois je ne lis pas la justice dans
son nom dans un certain nombre de cas
est proprement sidérant donc c'est un
axe de défense qui tient la route si on
entend jean sébastien ferjou c'est un
axe de défense qui se comprend en tout
cas parce que d'abord on connaît encore
le rôle que joue nicolas sarkozy hier
dans la droite française
il reste encore le mettre un peu du jeu
c'est lui qu'on vient voir quand on veut
être candidat c'est lui qu'on vient voir
pour savoir si on va pas être candidat
bon c'est l'homme qui donne les conseils
et on sait que parfois il fait un peu la
pluie le beau temps donc que les vents
se solidarise de nicolas sarkozy à
droite ça n'est pas très surprenant
après il faut toujours faire attention
quand même quand on condamne la parole
de la justice ce n'est pas encore dans
une décision de justice mais on est
quand même dans la parole de la justice
et les juges du parquet afin d'aider les
gens du parc nhl financiers ou bien
rappeler quand même qu'il n'avait
strictement rien de contre l'ancien
président et qu'ils ne sont pas dans un
désir de vengeance contre lui parce que
il a fait des misères la justice quand
il était président à travers différentes
réformes tout d'un coup les is on
imagine mal que un procureur ou des
magistrats édiles inverse dans un
tribune évidemment évidemment très
certainement mais il n'empêche que voilà
ils ont quand même tenu à frapper parce
que on pouvait les sanctionner quand
même d'avoir une certaine rancoeur
vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy un fond
entre le monde de la justice et nicolas
sarkozy ancien ministre de l'intérieur
puis président république qui a malmené
la justice a eu des mots tendres et les
mots tendres on se fout qui font que en
effet ils pouvaient les voir un
contentieux et donc ils se sont permis
de rappeler les choses après il faut
quand même s'intéresser au fond de cette
affaire
parce qu'on peut évoquer les problèmes
de procédure mais j'imagine quand même
que enfin j'espère là je suis pas
compétent pour en juger à la place des
jeux des juges et des magistrats mais
enfin j'imagine quand même que le cadre
juridique reste légal à partir de là il
faut quand même s'intéresser au fond de
cette affaire et le fond de cette
affaire c'est quand même des soupçons de
corruption et trafic d'influencé qui
pèsent sur un ancien président de la
république qui aurait donc il faut le
rappeler peut-être pour vos
téléspectateurs parce que c'est pas une
affaire non plus très courante
on parle de corruption n'y a pas
d'argent c'est pas si simple
donc l'idée c'est que donc il aurait en
quelque sorte vivant par l'intermédiaire
de son avocat maître herzog qui est
aussi un de ses meilleurs amis obtenu
des informations sur cette affaire
bettencourt que si tu es tout à l'heure
jean-sébastien en échange de quoi ils
pourraient aider monsieur azibert le
cette personne donc avocat à la cour de
cassation avocat général à la cour de
cassation
donc qu'ils récupèrent ces informations
pour sarkozy et qui rêvent d'en poste à
monaco qui il est vrai est un poste qui
je crois rémunérés 3 ou 4000 euros par
an qui se parent en plus un poste
financièrement très intéressant mais
visiblement très convoité par monsieur
ebay rédac est donc dans ces
conversations dans ces écoutes on entend
assez clairement nicolas sarkozy dira je
l'aiderai et il est même évoqué une
rendez vous avec un ministre d'état
monégasque
et là on ne sait pas ce qui m'est s'est
dit entre sarkozy et celui dit des sauf
qu'il ya quand même s'il est possible
mieux puisqu'il suffit après je voulais
sa part promis donc
et on ne sait pas ce qui s'est dit parce
que entre temps
herzog et sarkozy se sont rendu compte
qu'ils étaient écoutés dont ils ont été
mariés ça c'est votre théorie rien de
dénoncer ces incultes et randy
concernant justement ressorti des n'en
compte rendu mais justement il y à une
les magistrats nation c'est parce qu'ils
se disent on a eu des conversations
évoqué ça et ensuite à une non je ne le
sens pas je ne connais pas si bien
azibert je n'interviendrai pas pour lui
hélas les magistrats se sont dit mais
s'il dit ça c'est qu'il a dû se rendre
compte qu'il était sur écoute donc ils
ont mené une autre enquête ça ne vous
aura pas échappé puisque maître
dupond-moretti a même porté peut enfin
maintenant mini la justice a porté
plainte parce qu'ils avaient été
concernés par cette enquête là puisqu'on
en était venu à regarder les fadettes de
l'ensemble des avocats qui avaient pu
être rencontré lui bavette maître herzog
dont lui et donc ils n'ont rien trouvé
mais ça ils n'ont pas versé au dossier
pardon mais l'euro de la justice est
d'instruire à charge et à décharge et on
parlait de maître herzog parce qu'on
peut focaliser sur nicolas sarkozy
mais moi je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose de profondément choquant aussi
dans le réquisitoire qui a été menée
hier cinq ans d'interdiction d'exercice
professionnel je trouve ça un flamand
j'aimerais savoir danser ou gigantesque
un magistrat dans deux champs dans des
fermes pour le oui mais cinq ans
d'interdiction de son exercice
professionnel j'aimerais savoir quand un
magistrat en france a risqué sa quand un
magistrat en france at il risqué ça
quant aux nominations pardon mais quand
emmanuel macron d'hommes parmi les plus
hauts magistrats du pays des gens sans
suivre l'avis du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature comme il l'a fait à votre
avis pour quelle raison le fait-il vous
croyez que françois hollande ou même
nicolas sarkozy quand il faisait des
choix
dommage istres c'est que le faisait en
pensant que c'était des énoncés c'est un
échange de service ou que une mignonne
maquereau en bénéficier d'un soutien de
ses personnages qu'il a nommé non je
pense tout simplement qu'il pense que ce
sont des gens qui iront à minima dans la
même direction que c'est autre chose
c'est tout d'abord bonjour non la chose
mais qu'on nomme quelqu'un en échange a
effectivement de service qu'on demande
d'information par confidentielles c'est
au milieu vous aura pas échappé que la
justice est en général plus sévères pour
ceux qui ne sont pas au pouvoir que pour
ceux qui sont donc il doit bien y avoir
quelque part un lien entre la
politisation encore une fois pas de
l'ensemble des magistrats de celle-ci
registre et la manière dont les
procédures sur mon jeu et sert de la
série noire pour la droite parce qu'il
faut ajouter à ces thématiques brice
hortefeux l'ancien ministre
lui aussi mises en examen dans la sphère
du présumé financement libyen de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy
il devrait il faut avouer que tout tombe
en même temps aussi sûr j'allais dire
même le clan sarkozy brice hortefeux est
un terrain très proches de nicolas
sarkozy nicolas sarkozy est sur le feu
il ya une clause viande ont passé dans
un passé relativement récent et on sait
qu'il va y avoir en mars un grand procès
la fere bygmalion au cours duquel au une
fois encore nicolas sarkozy mise en
examen il est vrai un fait mineur je
crois que c'est un dépassement illégal
de ses frais de campagne
alors que les autres prévenus eux sont
inculpés mise en examen pour corruption
etc
mais ça va être un grand procès avec
douze prévenus plus nicolas sarkozy
on va encore une fois mettre toute la
sarkozie sur le grill donc c'est vrai
qu'actuellement on a le sentiment quand
même qu'il y a une envie de dire une
opération mais en tout cas une séquence
très difficile pour la sarkozie mai mais
sortons un peu du cas sarkozy parce
qu'on a l'impression que comme si ils
devraient voulais était un opposant à
nicolas sarkozy lui comme si moi je
soutenais sinon mais c'est ce que je
vous dis justement il a tiré ce qui
ressort des discussions commencent à
sonner la réaction de la droite annoncé
prenne forme je pense que c'est un sujet
qui devrait vous un atlantique au
d'ailleurs je pense que vous travaillez
même avec nous à l'époque mais l'avion
publié le mur des cons c'est quand même
une réalité il ya quand même des
pressions qui sont faites dans l'
affaire tapie a eu un certain nombre de
pressions qui sont faits qui ont été
faites sur des gens pour qu'ils
interviennent sur le président du
tribunal de commerce de paris notamment
pour qu'il se prononce contre bernard
tapie enfin les pressions c'est quand
même quelque chose qui existe
arrêtons de nous cacher derrière notre
petit doigt pour que la justice puisse
être rendue dans des conditions sereines
il faudrait quand même à un moment que
ces questions là soit mis sur le tapis
alors après ça ne veut pas dire que dans
les accusations dont vous parliez tout
soit à ranger dans la même catégorie
monsieur guéant est monsieur hortefeux
manifestement il ya plus de choses dans
les dossiers en ce qui les concerne
n'ayant même nicolas sarkozy s'est
détachée de sa veut pas dire que quels
que soient les accusations les
procédures menées contre les politiques
ni rien dans les dossiers en revanche
sur celle là encore une fois la
technique du filet dérivant pardon mais
elle est choquante elle n'est pas
acceptable dans un état de droit
allez on chante
jeu complètement dossier à gauche tout
maintenant et si anne hidalgo était la
candidate du ps en 2022 je prendrai ma
part a récemment lâché la maire de paris
n'en fallait pas plus évidemment pour
attiser la curiosité de tous ceux qui
s'intéressent un petit peu à la
politique en coulisses ces équipes
confie en off qu'elle pense alors on va
en parler avec un de ses très proches le
sénateur de paris rémi féraud qu'on
accueille dans ce match des idées
bienvenue rémi féraud merci de vous
joindre à nous emmanuel grégoire bras
droit d'anne hidalgo nous dit c'est une
idée intéressante
et vous qui êtes reproche également dany
delvaux que nous dit bout mais je vous
dis que elle elle a dit qu'elle voulait
prendre toute sa part parce qu'elle fait
partie de toutes celles et ceux qui ont
envie que la gauche gagne en 2022 qui
doit pas repartir pour un quinquennat
macron à 5 ans à nouveau d'injustice
d'inégalité de désordre de tension et
beaucoup d'amateurisme
avec en face l'extrême droite ou une
droite très influencé par l'extrême
droite donc elle a envie de prendre sa
part est ce que ce sera pour que l porte
elle-même
cet espoir de la gauche de conquérir à
nouveau et les responsabilités il est
trop tôt pour vous le dire mais je vois
que on a un problème de connexion c'est
dommage on va leur temps au jour voilà
on vous retrouve peut-être rémi féraud
ça a coupé est ce que peut-être vous
pouvez prendre votre téléphone je ne
sais pas pour qu'on vous entende bien
alors désolé voilà non bon il ya un
problème de transmission on va lui
demander peut-être de prendre son
téléphone et on va le joindre par
téléphone ce sera peut-être plus simple
je ne sais pas peut-être d'abord une
réaction
anne hidalgo pas vraiment candidate
juste qui prendra sa part mais non mais
non mais tout ça est un jeu de un jeu de
rôle actuellement
là on voit bien qu'on est dans la
stratégie
peut-être même que la coupure
téléphonique qu'elle a actuellement les
proches d'anne hidalgo sont là pour
essayer de faire monter le désir comme
on dit anne hidalgo est parti un peu
vite un peu tôt mais son nom est sorti
très fort elle a fait le même des
déclarations qui pouvait laisser
entendre que un peu tôt on peut prendre
beaucoup de coups jusqu'à une réelle
déclarations elle n'est déjà pas très
haut dans les sondages
quand on regarde les sondages elle est
juste derrière christiane taubira les
devants j'en ai parlé des sondages
internes entre les gens de gauche et une
élection avec des gens de droite autour
de 10
c'est donc à l'air elle n'est pas sot
clé encore suffisamment pour affirmer
une candidature mais je vais vous donner
quelques informations à mon avis qui
vont vous intéresser et plus précise que
seront bien entendre il ya un accord
anne hidalgo elle est candidate elle est
candidate
il ya un accord avec oak hill efforts et
à la rentrée un nouveau parti qui sera à
la fois
socialistes écologistes avec donc des
écologistes qui ne sont qui ne sont pas
tendance avec puyol qui ne sont pas dans
la tendance de la gauche mettant dans un
cadre du parti écolo plutôt tendance à
doha vont donc rejoindre cette grande
formation dont ils delgo devrait devenir
la candidate naturelle
c'est ça qui est en chemin maintenant
pour cela il faut effectivement que ses
amis sachent faire monter un peu le
désir d'hidalgo afin que anne hidalgo
progressent un peu dans les sondages
parce que si elle reste à 10%
toutes ces stratégies risque de
s'effondrer et ne tiendra pas parce que
comme vous savez il ya d'autres gens au
parti socialiste même des anciens prêts
à l'ancien président qui pense aussi
donc il faut pour que ça tienne que en
effet anne hidalgo progresse dans les
sondages et jean sébastien ferjou et
l'aurait raison d'y aller ni d'algos
c'est vrai qu'elle a quand même été
réélu à paris c'était pas forcément
gagné elle a peut-être gagné en
crédibilité au niveau national est ce
que en tout cas pour la gauche pour ce
qui est du parti socialiste qui se
cherche depuis quand même pas mal
d'années maintenant
auraient-elles raison d'y aller est-elle
la bonne personne pour le ps
je crois en tout cas qu'effectivement
elle est très bien placé dans cet
univers là puisqu'elle a fait la preuve
de sa capacité à avoir une majorité
assez différente qu'elle n'appelle pas
plurielle et qui finalement te
ressembler à ce que lionel jospin à son
époque avait su faire avec les
écologistes et
les communistes donc elle a une certaine
habileté ou même une habileté politique
certaine muller aboli l asus faire
réélire à paris à plus de 50% des voix
au deuxième tour sa demande et en
contexte un peu particulier mais alors
qu'elle avait des sondages qui
montraient qu'il y avait une majorité de
parisiens qui ne voulaient entendre
parler d'elle souffre d'aucun soulevé
aucun prétexte
donc oui anne hidalgo est un atout
politique allait certainement moins
flamboyante moins lyrique dans son
expression que peut-être at-elle
d'ailleurs moins de facilité de ce point
de vue là qu'arnaud montebourg ou que
christiane taubira mais elle est
certainement plus solide
après peut-être là où j'ai une
divergence avec il devrait enfin bien
sûr il faut savoir faire monter le désir
mais je pense aussi que l'enjeu pour
2022 n'est pas uniquement d'être
candidat ni même de se faire élire
l'enjeu il est au lendemain d'élections
et de pouvoir gouverner ça ça suppose
d'avoir reconstruit avant une majorité
d'avoir reconstruit un logiciel
idéologique et ça ne se fait pas dans
une campagne éclair de trois mois alors
on a pu entendre parler de nicolas
sarkozy tout à l'heure le général de
viviez ou dos des gens qui comme ça se
découvrirait au dernier moment et puis
se ferait élire dans un blitzkrieg
mais peut-être quand bien même ils
parviendrait-il que ils se
retrouveraient vraisemblablement au soir
du deuxième tour en situation
d'impuissance instantané donc je pense
qu'il est plutôt malin de la part d'anne
hidalgo comme de n'importe quel autre
candidat à la présidentielle du rêve de
faire un travail de fond avant alors
après effectivement il ya des coups à
prendre et c'est un équilibre à trouver
à n'a pas que des ennemis parce que
mécaniquement il ya d'autres gens qui
ambitionne la même chose la même chose
qu'à mais oui je pense qu'elle fait
partie de ceux qui sont 2009 les
intéresse vous parler de ce travail de
fond avant parce qu'il ya quelques
semaines parce qu'il craint justement
une guerre des ego le patron du ps
olivier faure a déclaré ceci et je vais
me tourner vers vous rémi féraud parce
que je crois qu'on vous a retrouvé par
téléphone je cite olivier faure il est
vraisemblable que nous nous mettrons pas
d'accord sur tout il pourra demeurer des
sujets de divergences sur les mesures
sur les priorités sur leur financement
je suggère que ce soit les français qui
tranche en gros olivier faur nous
propose une primaire sur les idées
plutôt qu'une primaire sur les personnes
est ce que c'est une idée qui séduit au
sein du parti socialiste qui vous séduit
vous qui séduit anne hidalgo ou pas en
tout cas plus personne aujourd'hui ne
pense vraiment à une primaire sur les
personnes donc ensuite que pour exercer
les responsabilités il faille clarifier
les choses sur en termes de projets
que ce soit pas une union de façade sans
savoir exactement ce qu'on va faire
derrière ça me paraît très important
quelle forme peut prendre cette primaire
sur les idées je ne sais pas à ce stade
mais il va y avoir un débat intense et
passionnant pour que ce rassemblement de
la gauche ne se fait pas sur des
ambiguïtés c'est d'ailleurs quand elle a
parlé de la laïcité ce qu'a dit ce qu a
dit anne hidalgo il faut que la gauche
se rassemble mais aussi en ces
différentes mais en clarifiant ses
positions sur sur les points essentiels
il ya quelques mois devant nous l'année
2000 21 ou en tout cas ses premiers mois
en sachant qu' il ya une échéance
électorale au mois de juin probablement
moins avec les régionales a passé la
barre sauf que le temps presse un peu
rémi féraud olivier faur suggère aussi
de changer le nom du parti est ce que
c'est une priorité quand on pense à
d'hidalgo qu'en pensez vous pour ma part
je pense que fait pas forcément une
priorité
et quant au lit l'effort parle de
changer le nom du parti jusqu'aux crois
que l'un de vos invités en parlais tout
à l'heure
pendant que nous étions en train de
régler les problèmes techniques c'est
comment le parti socialiste arrive à se
dépasser et à rassembler plus large pour
former rassembler l'ensemble de
notamment la gauche social-démocrate en
intégrant pleinement la dimension
écologique est ce que ça pourrait de
quelle manière cela pourra se faire dans
les mois qui viennent je ne peux pas
vous répondre à cette question mais
cette ambition
maintenant que les municipales sont
passés nous la partageons et nous avons
dû commencer est commencée en fait
l'argent sans perdre notre identité
politique que nous avons réussi à gagner
tant de beaucoup de villes dont paris
d'autant plus que ça tangue maintenant
et les écologistes quand même en tout
cas avec peut-être la tendance piol ou
oui j'attends ça tangue en effet mais je
crois que là aussi on voit bien qu anne
hidalgo si elle a pris cette position
sur la république sur la laïcité très
forte
quitte à se fâcher provisoirement avec
les écologistes
c'est aussi pour affirmer une stature
qui transcende la mairie de paris dont
elle devient un personnage politique
nationale et elle sait qu'il va falloir
quand même transcender cela parce que ça
n'est pas qu'un atout d'avoir été bien
élu à paris
c'est aussi un handicap quand on voit se
présenter l'histoire nier on nous répond
parfois que jacques chirac était maire
de paris m'était aussi député de corrèze
dont il avait aussi cet ancrage ans
laurence elle elle commence à dire
qu'elle est née à lyon qu'ils allaient
qu'elle est aussi lyonnaise bon elle
essaye par petites touches comme ça de
montrer qu'elle n'est pas que la
candidat des bobos parce que c'est ça
qu'elle a comme image aujourd'hui anne
hidalgo essais et c'est ça qu'il faut
pas hésiter sociologie des critiques
surgies qu'est-ce qui est ce qui bien
sûr est ce qui sera utilisé d'ailleurs
par ses concurrents par ses adversaires
qui n'hésiteront pas à mon sens à dire
avec sans doute un peu de bon sens que
anne hidalgo elle fait même à paris on
le voit la politique des gens qui l'ont
élu
elle n'est pas devenue la mère de toutes
les tous les parisiens et les
parisiennes a dit la mère de ceux qui
l'ont élu
et on imagine qu'au niveau national et
on devrait faire la même chose
c'est-à-dire être quelqu'un d'assez
déterminé comme elle l'est peut-être un
peu sectaire par moments avec des idées
très arrêtées et faire la politique de
ceux qui leur ont été vues tant pis pour
les autres
et après ça les français tous les
français ça s'est compliqué et c'est
effectivement mais il ya la version
négative que le côté sectaire est à mon
sens elle est incontestablement et
envoie dans la manière dont elle gère
paris mais ça peut se retourner
habilement en communication c'est à dire
que je ne sais pas si les gens cherchent
des gens brillants ils ont juste que
c'était quelqu'un de brillant avec mm
macro ils ont vu ce que ça donnait des
gens vibrionnant il pourrait voir
effectivement je parlais du lyrisme de
christiane taubira ou peut-être de la
créativité d'arnaud montebourg mais ça
leur rappelle aussi justement ces
politiques dans lesquels ils n'ont plus
confiance anne hidalgo elle a un côté un
peu bulldozer
a tf1 peu j'ai dit que je le ferai donc
je le fais je vais pas m'embrasser de
beaucoup de considération et ça je vais
vous dire paradoxalement ça devient un
grand atout c'est un peu celui
finalement peut-être que les gens
retrouvent c'est le général de villiers
dans un autre registre c'est à dire le
côté le militaire qui se pose pas des
questions à l'infini nécessaire un truc
il dit qu'il va le faire et bien il va
le faire et je pense qu'anne hidalgo l
acétate ou là alors c'est une ligne de
crête parce que effectivement ça peut
vite retomber dans le sectarisme et elle
en a beaucoup fait la preuve
mais par rapport à ses concurrents ça
pourrait être si c'est bien gérer une
forme d'autres
voilà pour le chapitre anne hidalgo à
moins que vous ayez quelque chose a
ajouté rémi féraud mais on s'arrêtera là
rémi féraud j'y pense pas que anne
hidalgo soit fekter mais par contre la
politique qui consiste à chacun d'eux à
dire à chacun ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre à mon avis est un peu à bout
de souffle aujourd'hui est que les
principes de lionel jospin dire ce qu'on
fait cher qu'on a dit je pense que il
mérite d'être lié au goût du jour et
fait vrai qu al hilal gauche il est très
sensible
merci merci en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées de
manière brève troisième thème de ce
match messieurs ce jour de deuil
national en hommage à valéry giscard
d'estaing c'est un petit peu passé
inaperçu mais une minute de silence a
été observée à midi dans plusieurs
institutions les drapeaux des bâtiments
officiels et ont été mis en berne jean
castex accompagné de plusieurs ministres
mais aussi des présidents des deux
chambres vous les voyez richard ferrand
et gérard larcher au musée d'orsay cet
après-midi musée parisien créé en 77 à
l'initiative de vge
on s'attendait d'ailleurs à ce que le
musée soit rebaptisé en sa mémoire dès
aujourd'hui pad annonce pour le moment
en ce sens ça viendra peut-être en tout
cas clément bonin réagi au micro de
notre journaliste alexandre poussard
tout à l'heure en salle des conférences
clément bonne ministre délégué aux
affaires européennes il a donc parlé de
vge l'européen il incarne une
inspiration européenne
pâques en france d'ailleurs les émotions
et les hommages ont été très nombreux
partout en europe parce que valéry
giscard d'estaing était non seulement le
chef de l'état mais un immense européen
quand il était président que dans le
conseil européen avec les première
élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel mais aussi après il a
été celui qui a créé un traité
constitutionnel européen qui n'a pas pu
aller au bout c'est vrai mais qui a été
une étape importante de débat et de
réflexion européenne et je crois que au
moment la france lui rend hommage c'est
toute l'europe qui remercie valéry
giscard d'estaing incarnation européenne
et incarnation de beaucoup de choses
président ultra réformateurs et un
dommage j'ai envie de dire presque a
minima quand pensez-vous jean sébastien
ferjou on est très vite passé à autre
chose c'est un ancien président de la
république finalement au delà de
l'hommage national qui l'a qu'il
refusait finalement il s'est pas passé
on avait dit il refusé l'image nationale
après je pense qu'il ya mécaniquement
autre chose c'est encore faut-il avoir
un certain âge pour se souvenir de
valéry giscard d'estaing ou d'avoir un
souvenir actifs de ce à quoi pouvait
ressembler la présidence c'est que
générationnel gratitude lié peut-être au
personnage qu'il était en utiliser il
était pas facilement personnellement je
pense que ça a été le plus grand
président de la vème république
après charles de gaulle et que quand on
regarde le personnage entre 1962 où il
devient ministre et l'année dernière où
il continue à donner des interviews il
ya une formidable cohérence on peut être
d'accord ou ne pas être d'accord avec ce
que disait ou penser valéry giscard
d'estaing
mais il ya une formidable cohérence on
n'est pas justement dans ces espèces de
postures marketing de jeudi à chacun ce
qu'il a envie d'entendre pour rebondir
sur l'elysée rémi féraud on n'est pas
non plus sur des gens qui peut-être d
analyse brillante mais ne s'efforce pas
de les accorder avec la réalité valéry
giscard d'estaing a su très
intelligemment déjà quand même avoir un
peu de sens politique
au début sortir du gaullisme tout en
étant peut-être paradoxalement le
meilleur héritier du gaullisme est à mon
sens un bien meilleur héritier du
gaullisme que jacques chirac était
pourtant censée pourtant censés l'être
donc il a un vrai bilan mais oui
effectivement peut-être parce que nous
vivons c'est un peu ce qu emmanuel
macron a dit peut-être parce que c'est
devenu tellement évident ce café giscard
d'estaing c'est devenu tellement évident
notre vide
notre vie qu'on ne s'en rend même plus
compte et peut-être aussi at il
bénéficié en contre bénéficié suis pas
comme on dit au pâtis voilà le monde
cherchait du lyrisme pour le coup car
accompagné l'élection de françois
mitterrand avant qu a eu tendance à
effacer un construire la fera de manière
qui succède à londres évidemment une
illusion le problème de reconnaissance
est un vrai sujet son fils louis giscard
d'estaing ce matin sur france info 10 il
était forcément meurtri de ne pas avoir
vu son action reconnue comme il aurait
pu le souhaiter avec une réélection en
80 c'était surtout de la déception de
considérer que ce qu'il avait réalisé
n'avaient pas été pleinement récompensée
par les français et quelque part on le
sent un peu dans cet hommage aujourd'hui
mais c'est là où on voit aussi le sens
réel de l'élection présidentielle d'une
certaine manière parce qu'on voit que
finalement ce sont pas les bilans qui
sont jugés c'est plutôt les hommes verts
que jacques si on peut tout ce qu'on a
autour de cette table qui n'a pas
réalisé d'immenses réforme lors de ses
deux mandats quand même ce septennat au
quinquennat avec quand même il faut le
rappeler dès cohabitent des longue
cohabitation
contrairement giscard qui lui un vrai
septennat et c'est le seul président
avoir eu une longue et vrai septennat
comme cela pour les grands chantiers
avec moi et non une seule et donc c'est
vrai que si ce qu'il a ratée par rapport
à mitterrand ou chirac de gaulle voire
même pompidou c'est cette rencontre avec
les français alors que pourtant il a été
inspiré chez kennedy il a fait du
marketing politique c'était presque
l'inventeur du marketing politique à la
française c'est lui qui a mis à part la
première fois des chanteurs autour de
lui dans ses campagnes avec brigitte
bardot qui avait giscard la barre sur
son tee shirt etc
donc c'est vraiment celui qui a pour la
première fois vraiment jouer cette carte
là et ça n'a pas fonctionné
les français n'ont jamais eu d'affection
pour valéry giscard d'estaing et il a
aussi raté de ce point de vue là la
suite sert la présidence il a eu une
longue période parce qu'il à 94 ans
quand même ça ça fait du temps donc il a
eu plus de 40 ans et pour autant bas
dans la presse il a tenté de revenir ça
un peu échoué
des romans
on s'est un peu moqué mais
malheureusement son texte n'a pas et
recule recueilli l'assentiment des
français donc il ya eu aussi une
déception sur le plan européen les
français mais aussi européens que lui
donc tout ça fait que en effet on juge
mal on juge mal l'oncle ben ils ont
peut-être paradoxalement parce que
jacques chirac était un bon roi de
france enfin le président c'est celui à
la fois qui incarne la nation et celui
qui dirige la politique quotidien
jacques chirac est à un bon roi de
france
un roi fainéant peut-être comme nicolas
sarkozy l'avait dit que ça lui a rendu
service les rois et valéry giscard
d'estaing un bon président mais un
mauvais monarque à la couverture de
l'ops était raymond barre qu'il disait
de l'époque où ils étaient représentés
en louis 15 donc en monarque un peu
méprisant lui a fait plus de mal
certainement que les diamants
justin tout en émotion a misé sur le
musée d'orsay je trouverais j'ai vu j'ai
lu de ci de là qu'on pourrait donner son
nom à la nef ou au parvis
je trouve qu'il faudrait lui rien faire
que ça soit on appelle cela me et merci
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette émission on se retrouve demain
18h 22h30 bonjour chez vous demain matin
7h30 au rayonnement de chimie recevra
stanislas guerrini délégué général de la
république en marche
excellente soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]